thank you Bill so hello everyone my name
is Benjamin Cordier and today I'm going
to be presenting my thesis defense
settled background prediction for
variant detection in a clinical context
towards improved next generation
sequencing monitoring of minimum
residual disease and human illogical
malignancies before getting started I
want to go over kind of quick overview
of the roadmap so I'll first be giving a
fairly extensive background and this
background is actually going to focus
broadly on how we detect variants and
the challenges they're in and then we'll
I'll be discussing some of the methods
we use and pipelines we implemented the
results of our research and then discuss
kind of some implications limitations
and future directions so first of all
what is a variant we see variants when
we align a sequence to a reference
genome and they can come in a wide
variety of structures so the most basic
are single nucleotide variants and these
can be insertions deletions and
mutations as many of you know we also
see more extensive very or larger
variants these are longer substitutions
insertions deletions inversions and
duplications and here we see them as a
structural variance and while not
Illustrated here we also see variants on
the chromosomal level and so these are
inversions translocations deletions etc
and these can occur on the chromosome
arm or the entire chromosome and for the
purposes of this research really going
to be honing in on the single nucleotide
variants now these variants also come in
two flavors of sorts germline and
somatic and germline variants are often
heterozygote and that means they exist
on a single strand of the DNA rather
than the given strand and it's
complement because when we sort variants
in a germline sample because of this
we'll actually see their allele
frequencies may concentrate around the
50
mark right here in many respects germ
lines represent the simplest case in
contrast somatic variants differ because
they arise spontaneously throughout the
lifetime and these are the variants and
mutations most commonly associated with
cancer cancer and others tissue specific
this regulation of the genome their
provenance greatly influences allele
frequency and will see clear deviations
in a sample away from the 50% VAF mark
and this can be the result of clone
allottee and also a global reduction in
purity in the sample somatic variants
are the primary variants that I'm
interested in and so when I'm talking
about variants throughout this
presentation those are what I'm going to
be talking about now as I noted there's
confounders of variant allele frequency
the first is purity which we also call
normal cell contamination
the second is clone Ally which means
there are multiple sub clones in the
sample and the third is copy number
which means there are multiple copies
within the cell of a given variant away
from the homozygote heterozygote norm
and for this research i'll be focusing
specifically on purity and clonality so
what is meant by sample purity normal
contamination or if we met imagine that
you have a patient with leukemia and you
want to sample their peripheral blood
we'll take a sample and instead of just
getting the pure cancer cells and the
subclones there and you'll actually also
get normal cell contamination and so as
an example if you have a heterozygote
that's at 50% and there's 20%
contamination we might actually see it
land at about 40 percent variant allele
frequency so this is a global reduction
similarly we also see a clone ality and
this is something that's quite unique to
cancer and other or somatic based
disorders and so this starts with a pre
malignant drivers mutation
and what we'll see is from there is an
initial clonal expansion where the
genetic instability caused by the dryer
mutation basically starts to include new
genetic variants and if we were to
sequence at this point we might see four
distinct subclones of the cancer and at
this point maybe we'll actually you know
go get a diagnosis and start treatment
now the treatment is the first treatment
is known as induction treatment and a
reduction induction therapy and it may
be completely successful but it also may
actually not get all of the sub clones
some may become extinct others may
continue on and because of the selective
pressure of the treatment may actually
diversify into new sub clones and pick
up new variation and at that point we
might do consolidation treatment and
this is a cycle that can repeat with
added complexity altering the clonal
structure of the cancer as we go through
it and an important thing to note is
that after each treatment we're going to
see reduced variant allele frequencies
of these sub clones and this is because
the treatments working but it can also
represent a challenge so why does it
represent a challenge
well because of minimum residual disease
minimum residual disease is defined as
the post therapy disease burden and it's
really valuable for for basically
finding whether a patient has the
potential to relapse and or they are in
a good remission a strong remission it
also can be really valuable in
determining whether we can pursue a
certain precision medicine approach for
a specific variant and whether the what
what titration in dose we can use so
this is a very valuable kind of clinical
measure and we detect this in the clinic
using next-generation sequencing assays
oftentimes as I mentioned with greater
treatment success the detection of MRD
becomes more challenging
the sensitivity of our next generation
sequencing assays can be about one in a
million cells and that means that in
theory the detection of a malignant
clone should occur at one in a million
cells but this is a reality that we
really don't see and this is due to
background error in sequencing data so
if I can walk you through kind of a
basic illustration of the variant
detection problem imagine that we have
many base calls lined up on the x-axis
and then we have allele frequencies
plotted on the y axis if we sought to
simply call variants visually by allele
frequency we might say that these four
bases on the left are probably variants
further we see this clear area of noise
that we might call the background
variation error or background to error
and from there we might say well aha
these these other areas could be
variants but it could also be error and
that's that's our low confidence region
so we wanted to create a kind of really
basic or basic visual model of how this
would work we might draw a threshold and
say at about 14% vary allele frequency
anything above we would say as a true
variant and anything below we would say
we're not very confident about so what
is this background error what is it
exactly there's it's actually quite
complex and there's multiple types one
of them is GC content bias which is
effectively if we it's an artifact of
oftentimes of the amplification and
library preparation process in the
sequencing and it Co varies heavily with
coverage another type of error is our
homo polymer errors and what we might
see is that if there's a homo polymer
run of C's in the first four C's we
might actually see that sequencer
continues doing
representing these seas when in fact
there's actually some Gees and so on and
this can be a record also now of course
the picture is actually more complex
there are also insertion deletion and
substitution errors and these can be
easily mistaken for those single
nucleotide variants and these Provari
with the species as well as population
or homo polymer errors GC content bias
and in fact they also Co vary with
platform error as well and so if we want
to model this error you could say okay
well let's make an error profile for
each platform in species and that'll
roughly help us tease it apart but
that's kind of a non scalable approach
and it would require a lot of legwork
and would require versioning of these
profiles and generally just not be ideal
so what we do is we turn to background
error models and there's a number of
tools that we can use to develop these
models and really help get around these
background errors and understand them
better so one of the most basic tools is
just getting distributions of the
sequences and the variation and these
distributions can be empirical from the
data or they can be theoretical
distributions such as the bernoullian
Gaussian distributions which are what
well understood we can also use Thresh
holding so we can take a global
threshold and put it across and say if
there's a signal past a certain point
then we say it's true variation or if
it's below this point we say it's not
true variation and this can be across
the distribution say at the 95%
confidence and we can also use local
threshold encodings where we take local
sequence context and use that to build a
distribution that changes as it moves
along the sequence and we can imagine
this happening kind of up and down now
once we have an error model the question
would be where do we put it
and the answer is that we currently have
many variant detection pipelines of
which the gatk is actually probably the
most dominant and that stands for the
genome analysis toolkit it's most
commonly used with Illumina platforms
and it actually has a background error
model built into it or part of the best
practices known as the base
recalibration module it's more
technically it's called the base Quality
Score recalibration module or BQ SR so
how does this model work well it works
by correcting based quality scores
rather than the actual basis themselves
it models the the platform errors using
known covariance and it does this to
adjust the quality scores so that the
variant callers in downstream in the
pipeline can have better data to call
their variants with so the rationale
behind recalibrating based quality
scores is that if we improve their
accuracy we can improve this downstream
variant calling but there are a number
of reasons why the b-2s our module may
actually not be appropriate for the MRD
use case for example the MRD or the BTS
our module was designed for the
detection of high confidence variants
and that's an approach that may be less
relevant in the clinical diagnostic
setting where false negatives can be
more consequential in essence that
excuse me the BTS our module may
actually be too conservative also the
platform base calling algorithm since
the development of BTS are have been
known to have improved a bit which may
actually make the b-2s our module less
relevant and further while it's unlikely
to be problematic the beat us our module
was originally developed for germline
data not somatic longitudinal data which
may while the model may work the default
and or recommended parameterization may
actually not be optimal so in light of
these background considerations we
developed the following research
question is the BTS our module reducing
our ability or the ability of the gatk
pipeline to detect low free
Thank You variants and also can existing
error correction software of which there
are quite a number the leverage to
accurately model background air and
somatic sequencing data within the
context of the gatk pipeline either with
or without bqs are and thus improve
sensitivity for detecting somatic
low-frequency variants from there we
developed our specific aims which was
first to create a framework to select
background error models and evaluate
their sensitivity and specificity for
the detection of low frequency variants
and then to apply this evaluation
framework developed to named one to the
ICGC TCGA dream challenge synthetic data
which has a true set allowing us to
benchmark evaluate and then recommend a
best performing background error model
that we could later validate in human
minimum residuals it sees data so our
methods we began by defining a model
selection criteria this criteria was
developed to allow for a principled
approach or selection of these
background error models and it had four
main goals which was to maintain
theoretical biological compatibility
compatibility with the sequencing
platform and also compatibility with the
high performance computing system in
this case x'q lab it also had to have
relative ease of use so what if you
these criteria really actually mean the
biological compatibility was quite
simple does the model actually have a
haploid or diploid assumption if it does
it's probably not going to be fit for
the somatic use case the sequencing
platform compatibility was that it had
to be either Illumina or ion torrent
compatible and the model had to receive
input in either BAM sam saffe queue fast
or fast and koala formats and then
computationally compatible with the UNIX
based operating system exposed a
functional API through the command line
and it can compile compile correctly
with the available clusters and ease of
use which is more squishy was that it
should have clear well maintained
current documentation and then have
relatively simple usage setup which
means minimum pre or post processing a
single error correction step and few or
no dependencies and then finally ideally
these would also be under an open-source
license so taking this criteria we
evaluated sixty-one background error
models and from there it landed on five
blue [ __ ] PFC lighter phase hammer and
quorum of these five that only three
were actually able to implement were DFC
lucu and lighter coincidentally these
air moles actually all use the same
error correction approach known as the
camer spectrum approach so next I'll go
into how that approach works and then
tell you a bit about how these error
moles take that approach but also add
their own unique flavor to to it
so first the camera spectrum approach
works by breaking up the reads into
Kaymer's and the cameras are essentially
a sequence of length k k being defined
by the user often times and so for
example here we might have these reads
and then we might say we're going to
choose a K of 7 and break them off and
now we have these Kaymer's right here
now once we've got a lot of cameras we
take them from the reads we essentially
create what's called a camera
distribution and on the x-axis we have
the coverage and we have the density
here so we see that the cameras are
roughly normally distributed and these
are what we might call the strong k-mers
or true Kaymer's and on the Left we have
low frequency cameras and these are the
ones that actually are may have errors
in them or variation and may not be
correct and so these are often called
weak cameras so out of the correction
work broadly speaking this approach used
in this approach a threshold is used to
classify the strong from the weak on
from that distribution and then often
leveraging and edit distant measures
such as hamming distance or Levenstein
distance
for example we may decide that all
Kaymer's off by Hamming distance greater
than two are to be considered weak and
those with an edit distance less than or
equal to 1 or strong so we have our
strong Kaymer's here with a distance of
less than 2 equal to 1 and we may say we
want to correct that C because we
suspect it's an error so we try G here
from these strong cameras we try T and
then we try a next we would use a
majority vote algorithm to select the
correction in this case a and then have
our corrected sequence output so as I
mentioned the FC lucu and lighter all
use this approach but they each add
their own different kind of version to
it approach so BF c is unique among the
3 because it's in its non greedy
algorithm essentially it may make a
correction but they also may revisit
that correction if it finds upon new
data that the correction may not be
optimal
it focuses specifically on substitutions
and it's also the only one that was
called aware so the FC works by first
classifying the Kaymer's a stronger weak
by counting and then for each read it
finds the longest substring of which the
camer is trusted if no trusted k-mers
are found it then finds the ones that
are 1 substitute 1 edit distance apart
and then looks through all of those and
finds finds those and then corrects to
them or corrects them ruku is a little
different it's a greedy algorithm
meaning that it it makes a correction
and it doesn't really revisit it and
it's also not quality where these are
the same characteristics for lighter
lucu classifies them as stronger week by
counting again much like BSC and then it
corrects unambiguous Kaymer's to strong
camers
so if you have a k-mer that there's only
one possible correction it will just
simply correct it to that there's
another approach it takes when it finds
an ambiguous Kaymer
which it takes the
and there's a real extension on it or
takes the read and does read extension
on it until it finds an unambiguous
scammer and then it uses a majority vote
algorithm to do the correction
the fault is also a unique feature of
Luffy that's quite important is that it
prevents or avoids false positives by
verifying corrections are supported by
multiple solid cameras lighter actually
takes a different approach to
classifying cameras between weak and
strong by doing random sampling and
using a dynamic threshold from the
camera distribution and its aim is to
turn every week Kaymer into a strong
Kaymer while minimizing the Edit
distance and it does not correct
ambiguous we came so it just skips right
over those so with our error models in
hand we then sought to develop the
experimental conditions for this
research so the pipeline conditions
shown here were first we're designed to
be able to compare the bqs our condition
and an OB q sr condition both without an
error model and with in combination with
an error model so for the condition one
we essentially have no bqs are no error
model and this is a departure from the
gatk best practices and then we have the
no error model dqs our model pipeline
and that is basically an implementation
of the beat us our practices and this
condition was designed to answer the
question is bqs are actually helping or
not helping in this use case and then
the second set of conditions was with
the error model
so that's BSC blue qu and lighter and
those were run both in conjunction with
v q sr and without beat us R so what did
the pipeline actually look like
well first we downloaded the synthetic
data and this was tumor-normal pairs
whole genome sequencing ran called QA QC
using md5 checksums and SAS QC and then
use sand tools to split the bands by
raid groups these were pre aligned with
VW a backtrack and then sorted those
regroup
and convert that converted them to fast
you stripping out the alignment the
reason we did this is the gatk best
practices actually require the use of VW
amen so we thought it would be best to
adhere to the that those practices from
there we would have essentially
validated ask use by read group and at
this point we would apply an error
models it was required so we would run
the selected background error model and
or if the condition required no
background or model we'd skip that step
and then we would take the the reads and
we'd shuffle them to remove any bias
from the previous alignment and then
align them with VW amen buy read group
from there we would actually merge the
alignment back to the original bam files
which was comprised of multiple read
groups and then step into the gatk best
practices mark duplicates with picard
apply beat us are or no bqs are
depending on the condition and then use
new tech to to do variant : from there
we would have analysis ready VCS so with
our VCS we performed an evaluation and
we did this using sensitivity
specificity and accuracy
among other statistics but we were able
to do this because the data actually had
a provided true set and it was synthetic
in addition to these metrics we also
made sense of Li and specificity curves
by tumor law law dogs score thresholds
and tumor log odds are log the tumor log
autoStore is defined as the log odds for
a base variant in the tumor sample
relative to the normal sample and so
from there we would have we would be
able to create these curves and then
compare the area under the curve to
understand the models performance the
data we used as mentioned with synthetic
data and it was sourced from the ICGC
TCGA dream challenge or dream somatic
mutation calling challenge we use three
data sets the first represented a
germline data set with 100% purity and
no subclones
second has 80% purity or 20% normal
contamination and those subclones and
then the third was 100% purity but also
had subclones in it so fifty percent
thirty three percent and twenty percent
the coverage this data was whole genome
sequencing and the coverage was about
thirty and the number of the percent of
positions with a coverage greater than
twenty x was between seventy six roughly
and seventy nine percent in total each
dataset had between nine hundred million
to one point 1 billion reads and these
were all aligned to the hg19 reference
genome so what were the results for the
b-2s are no beat us are without an error
model condition we found that the no
beat us are a condition actually
exhibited superior performance we also
saw that there was a divergent effect in
contamination where the first for the
contamination data set the no beat us
our or the bqs our condition remained
consistent but kind of strangely the no
beatrice our conditions seem to improve
which was not what we expected we also
saw reduced sensitivity and specificity
with clonality then for the no beatrice
are because our conditions with the BF
sierra model we saw similar performance
between recalibration conditions across
the board and each of us are exhibited
in the v2s are set exhibited improved
performance for the 20% contamination
and the clonality datasets the FC was
the only error model that actually
seemed to enhance the effect of beat us
our next we thought we did blue Kuen
Luca was found to be a surprisingly
strong performer there was no difference
between recalibration conditions
effectively Luca seemed to mitigate the
effect of beat us are entirely and in
addition we did see reductions
although slight in the contamination
clonality models or pipelines versus the
germ line and then for lighter we saw a
difference in recalibration condition
performance forceps one and two between
the Nobby to SR and vqs are conditions
where no bqs are outperforming the b-2s
our condition and again we saw
contamination clonality reduce
performance so how do the models compare
for the germ line the no model condition
performed better than vfc and lighter
for both base recalibration conditions
for blue goo we saw the best performance
comparable or luke who exhibited the
best performance and it was comparable
between the no BQ SRM beat us our
conditions and here the AEC's were a
point nine seven thirty one and point
seven point nine seven four six
respectively we saw a clear difference
between no beatrice on beat us our and
the lighter and no model conditions here
and then we also see in the germ line
data the first evidence that background
error moles can mitigate the effect of
the base recalibration entirely in BSC
in blue sue for the eighty percent
purity set blue qu exhibited the best
performance with comparable no because
our in beat us our conditions again they
you seized heroin point nine six one
zero and point nine five five eight
respectively Luke who was also an
exception in that it was the only
background error model that mitigated
the effects of beat us are in this data
set the no model no beat us our
condition followed with his performance
with slightly lower a UCS for the no
beat us our is zero point nine four six
six notably the FC exhibited improved
performance in concert with the beat us
our module in contrast to its no beat us
our condition which we found to be
somewhat surprising considering the
the layoffs or the other models
intresting lee for BFC even the 20%
normal contamination inset to these
AEC's were an improvement over both
comparable aggregate conditions in set 1
which exhibited the 100% purity overall
the FCN light lighter actually performed
relatively poorly when we compare them
seppuku and the no model conditions and
again we saw the mitigation effect in
the base recalibration for the Blue Crew
condition but we did not see it in the
BSE condition so for set 3 those that
were clonality perhaps the most
interesting set the base recalibration
mitigation effect was seen for all the
era models making BQ SR and nobuk us our
conditions comparable we also saw a
large difference between the no bgo SAR
and beatrice our conditions for the no
model condition and nobody to us are
again exhibited with superior
performance blue ku again exhibited the
best performance overall with AEC's of
0.9 3 3 5 and point 9 3 3 9 for the no b
q sr and beat us our conditions
respectively so in addition to these AEC
analyses we actually then went and broke
the data into five percent variant
allele frequency ranges and computed a
C's across these ranges and this was
done to see whether the AEC values for
the performance changed at different
variant allele frequencies in general
this heat map is largely as we expected
we see most ACC values between zero we
see mostly ACC values of about zero in
between the 50% and 100% regions right
about here we also see a tapering of a
UCS here in between 15 and 0% now for
the recalibration conditions we don't
see any specific vaf regions where BQ SR
seems to insulin sensitivity and
specificity either way that's to say
that the difference between the BQ s are
no bqs are
ditions the piercer arise from a
cumulative effect across all variant
ranges rather than any specific ranges
interestingly for both blue [ __ ] the no
model conditions we also see a tidal
clustering of performances here for blue
ku and here for the no model and this
continues across all the data so this
was quite interesting because in
contrast lighter which we see right here
actually extended down down farther into
the higher VAF regions and this is
likely an indication of the introduction
of false positives by the error model
which is kind of an own caveat to their
use in this context so the AUC of
sensitivity and specificity curves
offers a nice overview of how each model
performed overall but if we were to
implement these we'd actually need to
select a model and by the tumor LOD
threshold and to do this we basically
defined the optimal threshold as being
that which maximized the sum of
sensitivity and specificity so for the
no model no beach us our aggregate
condition it exhibited the highest
sensitivity for set two and three and
with sensitivity of nine point four
seven to ninety four point seven percent
and eighty six point nine percent
respectively and blue [ __ ] the blue
could be eat us our aggregate condition
exhibited the highest for set one which
was about ninety four point four eight
percent for all data sets blue true
exhibited the highest specificity over
all the best combinations of sensitivity
and the best combination of sensitivity
and specificity for sets two and three
this was in combination with the no beak
us our and for set one with the beak us
our condition so we see that right here
specifically for set one the blue to
beat us our aggregate was a tumor log
score of 12 had a sensitivity of 94
point four eight percent here and a
specificity of 94 point two one where is
that yeah right there thank you
and for set to the blue crew no beat us
our aggregate with a tumor LOD score of
11 had a sensitivity of ninety point one
one percent and the specificity of 94
point O three percent set three we also
saw a reduction as we expect in the
sensitivity due to the clone ality and
with a tumor log score of 11 the blue
crew no bqs our aggregate condition had
a sensitivity of eighty three point five
three percent without very high
specificity of ninety three point six
four percent as mentioned set three is
the set that exhibits clone ality which
is the most relevant to our use case and
the no model no beatrice our condition
exhibited the highest sensitivity for
this with it actually had a relatively
low specificity what's interesting is
that blue cout exhibited a slightly
lower sensitivity it was lower by about
three point five percent but it's
sensitive area specificity was much much
higher about thirteen percent higher so
this really highlights the trade-off
between sensitivity and specificity for
low frequency variation we're more
interested in the sensitivity perhaps
particularly in the clinical diagnostic
setting but specificity is really
important too and with an increase of
13% over reduction of 3.5% seeing if
there's a compelling argument that that
actually would be a superior model a
second heat map was of sensitivity
specificity a UTS was generated for the
lower frequent allele frequency ranges
and for this we use 1% VAF intervals
from 15% down to 0% the AF it's
important to note here is that the AUC
values do include false positives and
the data in here in fact highlights this
in evaluating the truth is that and
really scrutinizing it closely we found
that no variance actually exists below
the VA at 15%
threshold for sets one and two
indicating that the AUC s for these data
sets are in fact due to the correct
identification of false positives which
may have been introduced by the error
models if we notice that no model
conditions for set one and two are
largely clear of AEC's that are
bolstered by these false positives it
seems that the background error models
were the likely source of them so given
the lack of variants in sets one and two
in regard to the low frequency variants
perhaps the most important set is set
three and looking into it there were 66
variants between the 5 percent and 10
percent of the AF regions and 10 between
the 10 to 15% of the AF regions so even
once we examine set 3 more closely
however we don't actually see an
apparent increase in saturation of the
AUC so the ACS don't it seem to be
higher due to the known true positive
variance in the data so in some it could
be said that this data set does not
actually really help us get at the low
frequency variants quite as much as we
would like but this is discussed in the
future directions and there is a there
is a solution to this so to answer the
question did beat us are actually
improved performance well without an
additional background error model not
using beat us art did actually seem to
result in superior performance on this
data which interestingly was whole
genome sequencing data this the superior
performance was seen even with use cases
which exhibited 20% contamination and
clone ality and because you know we
actually saw an improvement in
performance in the germ line case as
well this kind of brings up a larger
question does the be Tresor module
improve variant detection for the germ
line use case in addition the second
question can existing models enable
sensitive detection of low frequency
variants what we found is that the
pipeline without the background error
model had the highest sensitivity and
specificity for sets 2 & 3
Lucan Dybbuk exhibit the strong a strong
balance of sensitivity and specificity
across all three data sets which was
something that was quite interesting and
broadly speaking the background of error
models I do believe would improve
variant detection depending on the
research question there is a caveat
though that these background error
models offer a potential to introduce
false positives if these models are not
parameterised correctly and they we
don't benchmark and validate them for
the use case we're interested in so
whether background err models can
actually improve the detection of
clinically meaningful low-frequency
variance does actually remain an open
question
so last laughs and another thing to ask
is this this presented here is the
germline best practices and it's
interesting because our our research
indicates that the base recalibration
didn't really help the germline use case
yet this is something that is included
in the best practices so really what
this may say is that we should we should
look at best practices with a grain of
salt make sure we adopt correct
parameterization definitely make sure
that we are benchmarking testing and
validating pipelines and not just
blindly following them so limitations in
future directions so as mentioned some
there are a number of limitations one of
them was that we used default
parameterization
for all the pipeline software modules
unless there was specific
recommendations that were made available
and some of these were in the
documentation but not all modules had
these we also use three error models but
there were other strong candidates I
mentioned earlier base hammer and quorum
and base hammer in particular may serve
very well for the MRD use case as
mentioned previously the data does not
contain true low frequency variants less
than 5% of variant allele frequency and
it was also generated synthetically
using vamp surgeon this is great because
it gives us the truth set but it's kind
of an open question how well band
surgeon actually really does model
true the true biological variation we
might see in cancer which is very
complex so future directions one that
I'm quite excited about is a six
dilution series that we've developed
with Rick presses the kdl that's the
night diagnostic lab here on campus and
this series was created from a serial
dilution of DNA from an AML pretreatment
diagnostic assay sample into a 35 day
post-treatment sample from the same
patient in the sample there are three
variants or their variants on three dean
genes ith n rows and n PM 1 and these
dilutions were scaled between 10% and 0%
and so this is 10 percent 3 percent
minor allele frequency 1 percent 0.3%
0.1 so these will definitely be able to
get the question of low frequency
variants and they're really nice because
we also have a truth set in these
finally unrelated to the dilution series
we came very close to deploying base
hammer and quorum and I think the next
step will be to revisit those also and
see if we can get those up and running
as well so next steps benchmark those
additional error models refine the
current pipeline to improve sensitivity
and specificity for low frequency
variants protection with the available
fixed dilution series there's also
potential for a second fix dilution
series to aid in this refinement but
that's kind of an open discussion right
now next apply these benchmark pipelines
to kdl data generated from clinical
samples sourced from serial minimum
residual disease a phase from AML
patients there's a lot of data at the
kdl that is that can be used for this
research and so this may be a really
great way to kind of push this research
forward and really understand what's
going on a little better
there's also research potential for
translation to clinical assays right now
when we do an MRI assay we don't
actually have a normal pair and this
research really required a normal pair
for the truth set so there's the
an area of research that we need to kind
of pursue which is how do we actually
translate these findings and these
pipelines into the setting where there's
potentially no normal pair and then also
further explore the development of novel
background error model so this this
might be something to do in the future
which is adopt or take advantage of the
serial nature of the MRD essays and use
known variants from previous assays to
help power the detection of variants
once they are after treatment when
they're at very low grade allele
frequencies so with that I'd like to
wrap up and say thank you to my thesis
Advisory Committee they were amazing and
the knight diagnostic lab the bead AML
initiative funded by the Leukemia
Lymphoma Society Diane dr. Lynch Wahby
Andrea ilk that just helps me organize
this so much and then of course Darrin
Eichelberger at the KBL helps me call
through a lot of their data and help
understand what was going on and make it
very very good for this research and
then finally my peers and the department
here it's a nice thank you and that I'd
like to take some questions
[Applause]
Josh as he faced in terms of actually
that of actually I guess juggling all of
these datasets and crunching them
multiple times through multiple error
models I mean that seems in intensive
was it yeah it was it was quite
challenging
um I think across all of it was 24
conditions you know that includes the
data so what what ended up happening was
we built a framework in it was actually
shell scripts and a state manager to
help sure we didn't double up on
computations and we kept pushing
everything through and it was done all
next to cloud and I think in total it
ended up being about 200,000
computational hours so it's quite a lot
but not as much as I've seen some other
acts ecology futures use so yeah I was a
challenging but I think I think actually
if we continue this research you may
actually update that framework and make
it more robust because right now it's a
little fragile of the shell scripts and
their scope management any other
questions
ether
yeah yeah the camer distribution let me
pull that up there we go so you know I
think they're the the tail there there's
there's probably very very few actual
Kaymer's there and it's possible that
those are just those could be sourced
from well this is coverage from I
believe the actual cameras themself it's
possible that it's due to read I'm not
exactly sure I actually didn't consider
it one of the you know one of the things
that I will say is that the the false
positives in the higher regions that we
saw I don't think that the distributions
we had could support the level that we
saw so I think there are more there than
we could attribute to a tail there I
thought so
do you have any plans to contribute your
framework as an open-source package you
think it's going to be useful for other
people um so it could be I think from
now it needs to be it needs to adopt
some better practices I was very
results-focused when developing it it is
open source and if they won't github
right now so you can feel free to you
know pull it do whatever and and yeah
see if you can get it worked for get it
to work for your research I think one of
the next steps might be to translate it
into a language that's a little easier
to work with and has better scope
something like Python maybe
but it is available and it's I would say
it's still in under active development
any other questions
[Applause]